they are on the brink of international
glory
and becoming national legends england's
players hope to grasp victory
as their predecessors did 55 years ago
and as they prepare for the last time at
headquarters in saint george's park
the country prepares for what will be a
historic national moment
it always comes back to tomorrow you
know we're in a final and
we're we're here to um we're here to win
so everything is important how we've
represented people and we're pleased
that
that uh that legacy has been there um
but now we want to go and and bring the
trophy home for everybody
england's passage to the final has
offered an uplifting narrative
in the most difficult of times they
entered this tournament with plenty
of doubters today they leave here
offering
purpose and hope and this is their
ultimate destination
wembley stadium will reverberate to the
sound of more than 60
000 football fans in what promises to be
one of the greatest sporting occasions
the country has witnessed of course
we've been knocking down barriers along
the way but we started this tournament
with a name to win it and we have that
opportunity
tomorrow night and um yeah to see the
fans on the street like they have been
and
see the reception that we've had as
we've pulled into the hotel here and as
was leaving st george's parkers
yeah just just showing us how how big an
occasion it is
if you haven't got a ticket for the game
or a seat in a venue showing it
then the message from police in london
is blunt
don't come to the capital because you
may miss out altogether
also off the pitch the fa were today
handed a 26 000 pound fine
after crowd trouble during the
semi-final against denmark
a fan shone a laser in the face of
goalkeeper casper schmeichel
just before that crucial penalty
this tournament has highlighted italy's
talented midfielders
the benefit of an experienced manager
and their robust
central defense there's no doubting
they're good
but then so are southgate's men
england are a good side because they
have a lot of good players on the bench
but if we've made it this far that also
means we're a good team
so we'll try and play our own game
sterling is certainly a footballer
that's come on leaps and bounds
we need to be very careful of him he was
a great coach england
certainly has momentum they're playing
in their own backyard
and today they even got a royal blessing
from one of the very few who was there
last time the queen said 55 years ago
i was fortunate enough to present the
world cup to bobby moore
and saw what it meant to the players and
it's most in part to him
few would have pointed to gareth
southgate as the most likely man to lead
the national team's resurgence
with gareth you know i just feel so
proud for him and uh
i'm so happy that he had that result
against germany
and now he's actually got us to a final
you know and it's just great that he's
he's doing everything right every
tactical decision he makes it turns out
to be the perfect one
um you know long may that continue and
it just needs to continue for one more
game and then you'll be
sargarath there's harry kane
for many of england stars it could be a
sleepless night
the mood of the country rests on their
shoulders
but whatever the result sunday's final
promises to be a mouth-watering contest
it will be a showdown etched into this
nation's history books
and a victory will bring a lot more than
just silverware
into man rasheed sky news st george's
park